Welcome back. In this video we are going to focus a little bit more on the plotting capabilities
which are offered by Pandas. We are introducing a new library called C-BON which is specifically
suited towards visualization of statistical analysis. So as usual we have the default
plotting library which is Matplotlib. Note that Pandas and C-BON are both just wrappers
around Matplotlib. So essentially without Matplotlib these two libraries won't work.
In order to exploit the visualization capabilities of Pandas or of C-BON you still need Matplotlib.
Matplotlib is like a low-level library which allows you to play with every single element
of a chart whereas C-BON is something that works at a very high level in the sense that
it is very much aware of the kind of analysis and the kind of data that you're already giving
it and it creates a lot of assumptions on what sort of data you're giving it and therefore
draws a chart. Now the chart that C-BON creates you can use Matplotlib to sort of tweak it
and change some of its attributes. What those attributes are and how you essentially keep
on changing a chart, tweaking a chart to make it look better is what this particular video
is about. So as usual let's run the imports and there we are. Now in this particular notebook
we are going to look at a new data set which is a data set from a fictional supermarket
and it has the details of all the orders that have been placed with that store and a bunch
of other details related to each order. So we are going to as usual read the file with
the readCSV function. This is the location to the file and note that here we are using
a new parameter that is used in the readCSV function which is called parseDates. Essentially
what this means is that we have two columns in our data set which are called orderDate
and shipDate. Now these are date columns. What parseDates is going to do is that it's
going to take this list and it's going to parse these particular columns into date time objects.
So it's essentially going to convert those columns not as text but as date time objects
and that's useful because date time objects have a lot of interesting characteristics like you can
directly extract things like the year, the month, the day, day of the week, hour, minute, seconds and
so on. Whereas if it was actually just present in text then you would have to do a lot of text or
string manipulation on that and that is not required when you have those columns parsed as
date time objects. And then we have another column called orderID which is just the unique
idea of each order. It doesn't really help us much in this case so we're just going to delete that.
And then let's look at the data set. So let's run this. So here is what we have. We have the
orderDate, the shipDate. Each row is particularly one specific order that was placed and there is
a ship mode which can be second class, first class, standard class and so on. There is a
customer name. There is a segment. Then the segment is basically the market segment to
which that particular product belongs. The city in which the order was placed. The region is
basically the south, north, east and west region of the United States. The category to which that
order belongs. So basically the first three orders are furniture orders, specifically bookcases,
chairs and tables and the second two orders are office supplies which are storage and paper. And
then the sales is basically how much sales the store made on that in dollars or whatever currency
and the quantity is basically how many quantities were shipped, how much discount in percentage was
offered for that particular order and what is the absolute profit in dollars that the store made.
So these are our columns. So what we're going to do simply is well one of the most important
things that people would like to know about this sort of a data set is what were their yearly sales.
So let's say that we simply want to take the year information from these dates and add up all the
sales to see what the yearly sales are. One quick way to do that is simply take the order date column
and when you access the .dt attribute of the order date column that gives you the underlying
date object here. So essentially if you just look at say df order date you'll see that it has a date
time 64 data type and if you were to actually get the dt attribute of it that is basically going to
give us access to the date time properties of it and then when I do a dot year I get the years
which is 2016 for the first two rows then 2015 and then 17 for the fourth row. I can also do
something like month. So it tells me that the first two orders were placed in August the second
two were placed in November and the fourth one was placed in April and so on. I can also look
at the date. So basically the first two orders were placed on the 11th of the month the second
on the 10th of the month the second and third on the 10th of the month and the fifth on the 15th
of the month. So I can use this sort of a thing to access any sort of an attribute of a date time
object. So let's take a look at what we're doing with that over here. Let's say that we do df order
date.dt.year which is basically the year part of this particular value and that we are going to
assign to a new column called year. So basically let's just do that and then what we are going to
do is we are going to group the whole data by the year. We have seen a group by operation before.
What it's going to do is take each unique value which is in year and it's going to take the sales
column which is this column and it's going to sum up that column for each year. So that's what it
looks like. So for the year 2015 this is the sum of all the sales that that store made. For 2016
it's this value and for 2017 it's this value. We can almost see that it's almost completely
incremental. It's increasing right. So here's a few types of charts which we can use to represent
this data. Well the first and foremost one of the things that we have seen is a bar chart. We already
have this variable this yearly sales data present in our panda series. We can just say xtf.plot
kind equal to bar and there it is. Now you see that we have three bars one for each year one for
2015 one for 16 and one for 17 and they are increasing which basically means that my annual
sales are increasing as the years go by. Now of course you see that in this particular chart
I know that 2015 is a little above 400,000 and a little below halfway between 400,000 and 500,000.
So just by looking at this it's not very easy to say what is the exact value or what is the
closest round number to which this height matches. So in order to change that I can simply add
grid attribute to it. So I can do something like this and that gives me a grid. So you see that
now I have the vertical and horizontal lines and I can just say that this one is higher
than 6000. Now of course it may be obvious in this case what the values are but when the charts
grow bigger and larger and when these x and y-axis when they grow in scale it doesn't become very
obvious and therefore it might be useful to introduce a grid. The other aspect of this
chart is that you can see that it's built up of three rectangles and they can have their own
colors and transparencies. So let's say that I want to do a plot but this time with a green
color instead of the default blue and I want to make it transparent. So basically I can do
something like this. So you see that now I'm seeing things in green but my transparency is
20 percent. So this alpha is a parameter which helps us control the transparency of each color
that shows up in the chart and the color is a parameter which tells us which lets us control
what color we want to plot the chart in. So I can convert it to red and I can say change the alpha
to 0.5 and that gives me a semi-transparent red color. Now of course if I set alpha all the way
to one which means that it's completely opaque it's not transparent at all. In that case this
is what it would look like. So there we are. This is how you can control the colors and the
transparencies of multiple colors. So the major reason why you have to use transparencies is
because sometimes you might have overlapping objects in your data and if you have solid colors
then some objects might get completely overlapped by something that is above them.
So that is why you can adjust the transparencies so that both objects even if they are overlapping
are suitably visible. Then of course let's add a grid over here as we have seen already.
So these are basically the types of charts. Bar charts is there and the next type of charts is
line charts essentially. Actually this is wrong. This should be line charts. We have already seen
what a bar chart is. Now the other type of chart is a line chart. Now actually if you think about
it it's basically the same information which is being plotted in different ways but you see
how different it looks and how unusable this line chart is. If you look at my x-axis you have things
all the way from 2015, 2015.25 which is I don't know three months one quarter into the year
then there is 2016, 2016.25, 2016.5 all the way up to 2017. So this is not renewable at all
and essentially if we just have three values in the x-axis and a bunch of values on the y-axis
it's just going to draw a straight line. So you see that a straight line is not very suitable when
you have very few data points to draw. In this case we have actually only three data points.
So when you have a very small number of data points to draw and especially if the values on
the x-axis are categorical values then we might not want to use a line chart. However there are
a bunch of different things that you can change even with the line chart. So for example one major
thing that we see wrong with this particular plot is that the x-axis ticks these labels that you see
here these are called the ticks. They are not at all readable. If we look at xtf we see that there
are only three values 2015, 16, 17 but we are seeing all of these 0.25, 0.5, 0.75 intermediate
values in there. So I could simply want to change these to reflect only these three values and nothing
else. So when I draw the plots I can do a set x ticks which is set the ticks on the x-axis to
the index of xtf. Now the index of xtf is 2015, 2016 and 2017. When I do that I get the same chart
but this time my x-axis tick labels are a lot more readable. They are certainly not as cluttered and
as confusing as this is. Then another thing we can also do is that we can take a look at the labels
and titles of this image. Now I know that I have here on the y-axis on the x-axis I have no clue
what is there on the y-axis. It's just some number that I'm seeing. So in order to make it self
explanatory I can add something like a set y-label which will say that these are my sales and they
are indeed our sales because that's the analysis that we have done and I can also add a complete
title to the whole chart something that appears at the top which says that this is yearly sales.
So let's run that by using set y-label we have created this title this label over here sales.
Now earlier we had label only for the x-axis now we have one for the y-axis as well and we have
added a title for the entire chart which is yearly sales. So for that we used the set title function.
There are a bunch of different line styles that we have used so that we can use. We see that this
particular line is a solid straight line. We can have a dashed line also. So here's a dashed line
similarly we can also have a dotted line and that's a dotted line. We can also have a dashed dot line
which is basically a mix of these two options. So that's how it looks like. You see a series of
that's how it looks like. You see a series of dashes and dots and whenever you call the plot
function the default chart that it's going to draw is going to be a line chart unless you see
that we provided a specific parameter which says kind equal to bar. It's only then that it's going
to draw a bar chart or you know a pile chart or any other kind of chart. By default it will always
draw a line chart and you can have a parameter called line style which can be attached it can
be dotted it can be dashed dot which lets you pick a particular style of the line that you want to
draw. Now you can also adjust the color and the width of the line. So you see that this is the
default width of the line. You can simply say that I want my line to be 10 pixels wide. So for that
I can use an argument called line width and I want to say that my color needs to be red and when I
run this you see that my line is a lot thicker. The width of my line is now 10 pixels instead of
the one or two pixels that was over here. I have a line that was fairly large and now it's colored
in red. I can also compositionally add the line style attribute to it. So I can say something like
line style is dotted or it is dashed or it is dashed dotted. Oops sorry that's a typo
and there we are. So you see that all of these attributes you can mix and match to come up
with the right kind of the exactly the right kind of graphic that you really want. So all of them
more or less work independent of each other. For example the line style has nothing to do with the
color and the color has nothing to do with the line width and the line width has nothing to do
with the line style. So they are all mutually independent. However note that this particular
combination of attributes will only work with you know line charts. They may not necessarily work
with bar charts. I can try a line width over here basically if I want to basically shrink
the width of my rectangle. So let's try that. That doesn't work you see it just stays the same.
I cannot I can't also use a line style because this is not a line chart essentially. So there
is no oh sorry that shouldn't be a five that should be something like dashed and you see that also
that doesn't work because that's simply not an attribute which applies to a bar chart.
Color does apply to a bar chart. So I can have a green color or
yeah so I can have a green color. I can have a transparency. So you see it's now green but
a little more transparent and here also transparency is something that you can say applies to this. So I
can write something like this over here. So you see that it's a very transparent red line over here.
So many of these attributes will apply to many of the charts but you know you can't just add any
attribute to any chart and expect it to work. So be careful about that but however note that you can
always look at the documentation of matplotlib or pandas to figure out what are the options you want
and therefore figure out what sort of parameters you want to set to come up with the right kind of
chart. The second most important types of charts that we will look at is heat maps. Now the yearly
sales line charts and bar charts that we saw here again they are reflective of univariate analysis
but when we go over to bivariate analysis we have to look at heat maps and scatter plots. So let's
look at heat maps first. So let's say that we want to basically create a cross tabulation of the
category and the region and put the values as sales. So what we are doing is we are going to
say that if you go all the way back to our data we have something called a category which is furniture
office supplies and something else and then we have a state or a region. So for each category and
region pair what are the total profits? So that's exactly what we mean by a cross tabulation. So
let's try that we are essentially saying that cross tabulate the categories against the regions
and sum up the sales. So we are saying that create a new data frame where the index or the rows are
going to be categories, the columns are going to be the region and the values are going to be the
sales such that they are summed for that category and that region. So let's see how that looks
actually. Before we actually draw the heat map let's simply see how the cross tabulated data
looks. So this is how it looks like. So basically for furniture that was sold in the central region
these were the sales. For office supplies that were sold in central region these were the sales
and for technology products that were sold in the central region these were the sales and that same
thing applies to the east south and west region. Now you see this is just a rectangular grid of
numbers one easy way to simply visualize this is to use something called a heat map and heat maps
come from cbon which is which we have imported as sms. So let's try that there we are. So we see that
there is basically a grid of colors in front of us each value is basically an intensity of that
color so this looks like a heat map whichever has higher values will be redder and whichever has
lower values will basically or rather higher value you can see that there is a color scale over here.
So I can look at the scale and figure out what these values mean. So essentially office supplies
in the south are very low because they're at the lower end of the color scale at the same time in
south overall it seems like the sales are pretty low and technology in the east is very high it's
way over 200,000 dollars and that makes sense on the east coast there are a bunch of technology
specific business right. So that is what a heat map is it essentially plots a two-dimensional grid
of numbers with colors so that you can see a heat map and we have these four regions and we have these
three categories. Now just like bar charts have thickness and bar charts have colors and
transparencies line charts have line styles and line colors and x-axis labels y-axis labels ticks
and so on heat maps also have their own elements the most important element of a heat map is the
color map so this is one particular color scheme that we are using we can use multiple other color
schemes so this is a scheme called blues when we use that we get everything in shades of blue
so we see that very high values are over here which is technology in the east just as we saw
over here and we have very low values for office supplies in the south which again you can check
by looking at the color legend bar over here note that color maps are very useful when presenting
to an audience there may be people who are in fact color blind in your audience and you might
to consider you might have to consider picking heat maps that are or other color schemes that
are suitable for anybody's viewing at the same time depending on what sort of a projector you have
or what sort of a medium you are using to plot your charts you might have to pick the right color
map for example if i wanted to use this particular thing so that you know if i wanted to send this
to a newspaper then i probably wouldn't use this color map i'll probably use something like
a gray color so that might actually work out better in the case of a black and white newspaper
say i can also have a green color map which gives me something like this so there are a bunch of
color maps the default one that we usually use is viridis so i think it's a small v
yeah so this is also one of the most famous color maps that matplotlib uses you can use
and pick the right color map depending on who your audience is where you are going to be plotting
this and if it is made for consumption outside the jupyter notebook
and then of course there are seller notations now what i'm doing with this is that i'm looking at
the color of a particular cell let's say i pick a region i pick a category i look at a particular
color and then i look at this scale to see what closely matches that color now if i'm not very
careful i can easily go wrong for example i don't know if there is a difference of shade between
this color and this color i have to be very careful while looking at this and most people
in your audience are not going to be that careful so one quick way to deal with this is to show
values right in the box itself so we can do it something like this so we have a blue color map
and the values that are basically the sales of a particular category versus a particular region
are printed right in this box straight away right but these are printed in the exponential
notation i want to see the exact value so i can use a particular format the g format is basically
just going to turn this into an integer and the anot equal to true format is basically going to
annotate each box with the value so when i run this formatting i get the exact integers out
and i see that not only does my color help me find out the higher and lower values the value
actually tells me what the real value is and that's useful because then the density of the color or
basically the the hue or the you know intensity of the color it serves the purpose of drawing
my attention to a particular box but when i actually want to look inside that box i can just
read the value so both our problems are solved in this sort of thing however you can realize
that you know this works only because it's a three by four matrix we have only 12 values
what if you have something which is 10 by 10 or 20 by 20 or even larger there it may not always
work there it wouldn't suffice to simply print out all the values there you're probably better
off simply looking at the colors because if your heat map is large then you know you simply cannot
print color values inside each or you know you can't print numerical values inside each single
box there's just not enough space to do that the next thing that we need to figure out is the
scatter plot so c1 also gives us a scatter plot as you remember scatter plots are the easiest
graphical way of doing bivariate analysis when both the variables are continuous variables so
let's say that on the x-axis we want to plot the quantity let's take a look at our data frame once
again that's our data we have something called quantity which is the number of products shipped
and the discount so the idea would be that if i order multiple quantities of the same product
in bulk i should get some sort of a discount so let's see if that is true and when we do that
we see that there is absolutely no correlation for all types of quantities we are seeing that
all types of discounts are present so basically items that have been ordered twice at a time
they have discounts which go all the way from zero percent to eighty percent so this doesn't
make sense at all the assumption that higher quantities lead to higher discounts is just
false and what this simply means is that there is no correlation between discount and quantity
right so this is although it's it's a disappointing scatter plot but nevertheless it is a scatter plot
it's a scatter plot that doesn't show any linear trend or anything like that but nevertheless it
is a scatter plot we can maybe also try something like what would you have it so let's say i have
quantity versus sales and there it is so this is a slightly more well meaningful scatter plot because
we see that the sales for quantity also are fairly random you have quantities that have been ordered
once which make very little business but at the same time you have quantities that say at the
level of five where if you order five products at a time it may make sales anywhere from zero to
hundred and seventy five seventy thousand five hundred dollars but that seems to be an outlier
this again seems to be an outlier so you can use this kind of a technique to figure out correlation
between two three things just like heat maps bar charts and line charts before it scatter plots
also have their own attributes one of the most important attributes of a scatter plot is something
called a hue or a density so let's go back to the quantity and discount scatter plot that we had
earlier and we say that we want to hue it that is we want to color it by the profit and we give it
the data and we say that we want to use the blue color scheme so there it is so you see that now
we have the same scatter plot but the color of each plot can be changed according to how much
profit that particular order has made so we see that most of these orders are making almost zero
profit there's there are some which are slightly darker some which are very light so we have
profits between zero to minus five thousand which is basically just state of loss but then you know
this is one way where you can add one other dimension the quantity being one dimension
that is count being another dimension and the profit being the third dimension but since it's
a two-dimensional plot we don't have a third axis here to show the profit so we encode the profit in
the color of each marker separately let's try and change the profit to something like
sales you see here we have a fairly different plot in the sense that almost
most of the plots have gone away and you can see some dark spots here and there so you see you can
use the hue to encode a third element of information as well then you can also change the marker style
and sizes so here the marker style was basically a circle which was blue colored you can also
change the size so basically i can say that my x is quantity y is discount u i have already the
color that is i've already used that to encode the profit i can quantify the size by sales
so let's see that this is what we get you see that there are some bigger
circles and there are some smaller circles those are basically something that you know denote the
size of the sale that you have made so larger circle means a larger sale and the darker circle
means how much more profit you made so now here we have a way of encoding four different types
of information just like compared to the three before here we have four types of information
we have the quantity we have the discount we have the profit and we have the sales quantity
is represented by its offset on the x-axis discount is represented by its offset on the y-axis
profit is represented by the hue or the darkness of the color and sales is represented by the size
of the bubble so you see that this here is a bigger bubble than this particular bubble which
means that this particular order made a larger sale than this one so now we have gone from
representing only two types of information to representing four types of information
using different visual elements that are present within the same plot this is something that you
can keep on configuring endlessly just by changing x y q and size to different columns of the data
set and therefore coming up with better and better plots until you have the right size of course here
we had size as a function of one of the columns present you can also have it fixed so say i want
to keep it fixed and i just want every plot every dot to look the same way so there it is we basically
have every single circle with the same size no matter what its attributes are the only thing
that it shows us is basically the hue x and y so the quantity discount and profit are the only
things we can infer from it but the size is fixed i can also change the marker style itself so these
are all squares i can convert them into stars so i can look at this like that i can convert them
into pluses which would make it appear as crosses of course this is not at all readable even stars
are not completely readable but you can pick and choose the right kind of thing to show
the different kinds of things so let's say that i would want to use stars for furniture sales
versus dots or circles for technology sales versus for office supplies i want to use something like
you know diamonds or something like that so yeah
something like that i can use that as well so here again you have ways of using markers
to encode or represent categorical data so just like you have x and y representing numerical data
u or sizes representing numerical data you can use markers to represent categorical data as well
so let's say i use a different marker for a different category of sale that's perfectly
valid the idea is that you are able to encode different types of information in different
visual elements of the same chart that's broadly how we do effective data visualization with python